answer this question what matters more
to you
than money now ask yourself
why those are your values
hey everyone i'm elaine weltroth and i'm
the editor-in-chief of teen vogue
i spent over a decade building a career
as a magazine editor it's really scary
to walk away from that
i looked up one day and realized that i
had more dreams
gone are the days we work at one company
for
our entire lives it's about dreaming
out of the box and designing a career
path
that's as unique as you are
[Music]
this master class is for all the
creative entrepreneurs
the multi-hyphenates which i like to
call moguls in the making
big dreamers who just need a little bit
of help figuring out how
to map out exactly how you're going to
make all
of your career dreams happen in this one
lifetime
we're going to talk about the difference
between good writing and great writing
marketing and social media team building
it takes a village y'all
what is your zone of genius that sweet
spot
at the intersection of your passions
talents values and your skills
understanding
your zone of genius allows you to stay
focused on what matters the most
it is never too late to pivot fear is
going to be part of the process you're
thinking
how am i going to pay my bills what
about health insurance girl i'm tired of
ramen noodles
i've been there i completely get it we
have to figure
out how to dance with fear to be able to
reinvent
ourselves and our careers time and time
again and i want to help you
craft the plan to make it happen
i'm elaine welteroth and this is my
masterclass
you